new at 11 a plot of BLM land up for sale
but only to the city of Las Vegas plans
are to build a new master community in
the Northwest part of the valley just
off of the 95 and Sky Point Drive but as
Ryan mathie shows us there are concerns
with those who ultimately pay the price
and how realistic it really is amongst a
23rd consecutive year of the state's
drought
nearly a hundred million dollars for
almost a thousand acres that's the
trade-off between the Bureau of Land
Management and the city of Las Vegas for
most of this a master plan Community
with Community concerns there's not
enough water for it
a potential in an area that's inundated
with new development 939 Acres of
Northwest Scenic views that the BLM
wants to sell for a hundred thousand
dollars an acre or 94 million altogether
I don't know exactly what's going on the
concern of several who live nearby like
Ava Klein who says they can't find
specifics of what will go in but what
she does know Lake Mead is getting lower
in the last year we couldn't even put
our kayaks in because they watered up so
much that they cannot find a place to
put in every time we build we come
closer to the point where we have less
water than we have available water
concerns shared with Peter Foley he
points to eight percent of Nevada's
water allocation that was cut in the new
year but what's increasing water rate
increases as of January the 1st I took
these concerns to those in charge the
Bureau of Land Management directed my
questions to the city a city
spokesperson only mentioned plans are
for a master planned Community but how
many homes and businesses and how much
water will each use that's unclear
documents say it's quote designed to
strengthen Community Development
opportunities in the Northwest providing
employment services and a gateway to
surrounding Recreation it just doesn't
seem very fair that um the people of
Vegas have been asked to conserve at the
same time when they're building more
all right so here's how the BLM says
that 94 million would be used five
percent to the state of Nevada's general
education fund then 10 percent to the
Southern Nevada Water Authority and the
other 85 percent used throughout the
state for projects like Park and trail
development acquiring environmentally
sensitive land and hazardous fuel
reduction but the sale hasn't happened
yet the BLM is asking for public comment
through February 21st but they are only
accepting those comments by written mail
the Las Vegas city council also already
to choose a developer back in 2019.